dans les yvelines les élus ont également
réagi à cet événement valérie pécresse
dont présidente de la région ile de
france parle d'un proxy calamiteux et
d'un coup de tonnerre sur l'europe en
encourageant une réponse franco
allemande
elle en profite également pour faire un
petit coup de pub à la région
ile-de-france en invitant les
entreprises qui souhaitent rester dans
l'union européenne à venir s'installer à
paris le président du sénat gérard
larcher parle lui d'une mauvaise
nouvelle pour l'europe
il appelle à relancer le projet européen
a sollicité le président pour tenir un
débat parlementaire et cela le plus vite
possible
de son côté le conseiller régional
yvelinois et dieye tu sais dit inquiet
tout comme benoît hamon député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines qui se
posent la question du changement pour
l'union européenne plus proche de nous
jean michel fourgous maire d'elancourt
tweet ceci le couple franco allemand
doit se renforcer d'urgence